a poetic form congenial to Robert
Browning so was kind of a form that was
good to him that worked well for him a
poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue it led him
explore a character's mind without the
simplifications demanded by stage
productions so just the way I read it I
had more pause here than just a comma if
I really read it actually what the
common would been a poetic form
congenial to Robert Browning was
dramatic monologue and let him explore a
character's mind without the
simplifications demanded by stage
productions this is really kind of a
separate expression right over here did
it really demands more pause I would
think about instead of a comma here you
could put a period there you know kind
of a full stop or maybe a semicolon
which says well it's a little bit in
between it's it's it's it's a related
thought but we're gonna pause a little
bit more so I would put at least a
semicolon there if not a period so let's
see what what else they they put over
here a poetic form congenial to Robert
Browning was the dramatic monologue well
obviously this was as is we already said
that we don't really like that one a
poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue which let him
explore a character's mind without the
simplifications demanded by stage
productions actually this one works
pretty well because now it's not it's
not a separate statement right over here
here we have this we're having this
relative pronoun which and you have the
dependent clause so it's really telling
us more about about what why he the the
dramatic monologue was a poetic form
congenial to Robert Browning so the
because it's not an independent
statement it actually works well with a
comma here I don't feel the need to put
a period or a semicolon so this is
actually a pretty good this is actually
a pretty good solution but let's look at
the other ones a poetic form congenial
to Robert Browning was the dramatic
monologue that lets him explore a
character's mind without the
simplifications demanded by stage
productions so this feels when they're
using that here it it feels much more
like they're they're telling us a
certain
type of dramatic monologue so not just
all my dramatic monologue but it was it
was in particular the dramatic monologue
dramatic monologue that lets him explore
a character's mind but we're not saying
that it's just that's the only type of
dramatic monologue we're saying all
dramatic monologues let him explore a
character's mind without the
simplifications demanded by stage
productions that's what dramatic
monologue ah is just someone talking
without you know other stuff really
going on and all this other other fancy
stuff so this is to me see kind of
changes the meaning of it it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't it's not wrong
grammatically a dramatic monologue that
lets him explore a character's mind but
it's changing the meaning it's saying is
it feels like it's qualifying the type
of dramatic monologue but but the
intention of the sentence is that all
that the reason why it was that dramatic
monologues are good for Robert Browning
or that all dramatic monologues let him
explore a character's mind without the
simplifications demanded by stage
productions so I'll rule this one out
I'll kind of a weak scratch out it's not
you know it's just a changing the
meaning so let's get these other ones a
poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue semicolon
letting him explore a character's mind
without the simplifications demanded by
stage productions so they're giving me
the semicolon that I kind of kind of
wanted in the beginning but then they're
but then they're they're they're making
this into it's not no longer the second
that what we have after that is no
longer kind of an independent phrase
like it was or an independent but almost
you know clause like it like it was
before now we're saying letting him
explore this actually would have felt
better
with with a comma here so I'm gonna I'm
gonna throw this one out a poetic form
congenial to Robert Browning was the
dramatic monologue by letting him do so
this one so it was a was dramatic
monologue and then we immediately go
into by by letting him do exploration so
this is was I guess I guess how the
dramatic monologue but once again be is
much clearer and that they're saying the
dramatic
monologue which which is referring to
the dramatic monologue lets him explore
a character's mind so I drooled this one
out this one actually is quite awkward
in the way it's phrased